[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record and we talk about
whatever we want and today we have huck
ya a choreographer a dancer a performer
and incredible mind and also side note
by the way make sure to subscribe to our
channel if you want to see more of these
videos but yeah thanks for coming thank
you
this episode is brought to you by
upstart upstart is the first artificial
intelligence the intelligence lending
platform designed to improve access to
affordable credit they go beyond the
traditional credit score when assessing
your creditworthiness so they look into
stuff like your education or job history
all the stuff that's not in the typical
application to get a better feel of who
you are in the form of a smarter
interest rate that's right they make it
fast simple and easy to check your rate
in just a few minutes the best part one
that loan is a hop I'm like what is it
with okay so this is the best part once
the loan is approved and accepted most
people get their funds the very next
business day
unfortunately Sunday is not a business I
hate that what Monday you'll get it so
over 300,000 people have used up start
to pay off credit cards or achieve their
financial goals but what if it's a
Friday then you got to wait two more
days Steve okay so free yourself from
the burden of high interest rate credit
card debt by consolidating everything
into one monthly payment with up start
see why upstart is ranked number one in
the category with over 300 businesses on
Trustpilot
and hurry to up Starcom slash record to
find out how low your up start rate is
that's right so checking your Rea only
takes a few minutes and won't affect
your credit again go to up Starcom slash
record and thank you for upstart for
sponsoring this video go in the
description box below and get approved
for that loan yay well thanks for coming
on thank you thank you a new hairstyle
he's always got different hair yeah it's
just like changing clothes oh you look
you look better from the air bender like
every time I feel like you should be
like when that movie comes out should be
in that movie I've never never watched a
vendor well that sucks
to me it's like my hair is I get through
the wash constantly and it's just
getting worn a more
warned change-out meal as the red part
is that your real hair added extension
hmm that's a wig yeah it's a we know
because I change the color of the actual
hair last time and because you braid it
it gets like weaker you dyed it yeah I
remember you cut one and then you like
you have like oh yeah yeah I think I had
that yeah the real question is how do
you have Christmas bells but it doesn't
make a bell sound well when it comes
Christmas it will what would you do if
one of your friends came and just shaved
it all off
who would I get you met I think so I
think so why could they come up with a
sit with a pair of shears and just well
guys someone knows right you could
connect it with a couple years and still
have it again hey when you guys do shows
like when you guys do shows do you share
rooms like all the buddies sometimes do
they play pranks on you when you sleep
not not like that or used to I feel yeah
like crazy like random stuff where we
would just raid someone's room and you
would just throw everything on their bed
while they're sleeping like anything
it's very non matera like that's an
Asian Japanese I don't know if I've
never heard specifically like Asian
pranks
there's konchog Japanese there's some
Japanese shows I have the concho it's
like I put this on your lines over you
go like this praying hand to a [ __ ]
stick it up their ass look like a
[ __ ] hurt stop that's just a thing
when it's not really a prank is it it's
just that it's like a handshake it's
like a bad it's like credit for sexual
assault maybe yeah white prank
it doesn't really know just random stuff
yeah that's cute
yeah I don't remember such a creative
mind
really curious to see like what have you
come up with in terms of like you your
mind really just goes out there I'm like
how so give me example I want these are
Chris he's dancing though have you seen
any of his videos just watch it any of
his videos on his IG like concept art
like Westworld [ __ ] but in his brain
yeah it's so dope but I don't know if a
pranks are funny man's game and I think
you guys are too sexy too serious
Tiffany sexy and serious may your sexy
prank I don't know if you can oh yeah
maybe we're you guys all each other up
oh I know a sexy time oh stop I know a
sexy prank so like let's say like you
get seduced by a really good-looking guy
and you're like oh my god
and they're like and then like four
ladies right and then I didn't and then
information you guys are you guys about
to do it right like like the hotel rooms
all nice with [ __ ] romance and [ __ ]
and and he goes I'm gay and he runs over
and he runs out of the room that was
sexy reveal to the best sexy playah
yeah that's pretty sexy well I mean it's
sexy leading up to the part where he
does it he does it give it to me oiled
up though
I mean I could be wrong but I don't
think for me personally it's not like a
blue ball situation I'll just be like oh
well that sucks you don't be a good
prank is if we bring in new guests and
then we're doing ad reads and we're like
hey man can you read this and we have
them read that read is that a pray like
some crazy [ __ ]
doing this and it's already awkward
cause like we what I'm doing a brand
deal for you guys and then please this
video is brought to you by Isis if
you're tired of your government and you
would like to switch teams oh my god
Syria comp can be a freedom fighter
yeah but oil them up though Oh oil
debuff sexy so they got a shine to have
to be shirtless and if they read the
brand
yeah that's a good point we'll try it
now that you're in on it can't do it to
you we'll try it to the next one yeah
we'll bring one of your other crew
members hopefully I'll get to witness
one of them they say exact hey are you
are you a legal immigrant your legal
right yeah I have a green card
oh I'm glad I don't know it wouldn't cuz
I don't only prove it what'd happen if
you could prove it I mean they'll have
to carry it everywhere right it's not
like a driver's license you have to
carry I think it fit American citizen
performance citizen's arrest on that
yeah but I don't want to be a company
that hires illegals right so I know he's
a visa he's a foreigner so I'm like what
yeah do I want to get in trouble for
hiring illegal immigrants I have to
check you know that's just one of the
things I'm I'm just yeah I guess
technically I'm a resident but not a
says are you trying to become a citizen
um maybe you lose your privileges over
there
I don't think so I think you get the Jew
but I feel like we're the Japanese
possible in the green card like
traveling wise what are you Japanese
citizen this last time technically I'm
Japanese possible oh yeah cuz your
parent you just worked they were working
there and it okay okay
military base no no no like business
just international business Sony he used
oh [ __ ] I think I've heard of them yeah
and I used to make like robots and stuff
Sony oh I know the former see if or
something left of Sony oh that's another
Sony guy Sony PlayStation piece he died
he's he's my replace dictionary my
father's still alive so probably wasn't
he said nothing he committed suicide
that's why I stopped thinking I was like
oh so that's not the good part of the
news that I want to say but he was a
great friend I was gonna say another
person that I know
of Sony he's a Sony executive who my
friend former and you know why he's
former he was a part of the me too and
he got in trouble for something yeah
he's a horny little man but then my
friends Fran do any of these friends
that [ __ ] good news wait he's getting
her the good news he's like wait and he
gets here's the good news
yes here's the highlight my friends
friend the truth is a personal trainer
what the [ __ ] is your point today
literally today that's not like one of
Nicky's dreams yes it's true there's no
plot it just keeps going the plot was
I'm trying to relate because Sony oh I'm
trying to name-drop we were part of an
Asian Dance Crew in school uh not in
school I mean I I had an agent um
where'd you start cool quests good that
was your start yeah well I mean I've had
different oh okay I thought like you
first joined them and not in high school
so I'm thinking you're like 19 and you
just don't care me how old was you well
when you started dancing 15 16 oh nice
okay well you went into crafts quest
crew at that age no no I started quest
when I was like 22 because I know a lot
of quest guys like they've done dope
[ __ ] wander own and then they kind of
like you know come down they graduated
into quest right right right
well I did different groups and then I
did I think I was in a different crew
first when I did so think you dance and
then I think it was after that or
something that we made in the dance
world is it similar to I'm gonna pull
from my own experience the gang world
where like you are or else people are
like hey man you were a Kinjo like what
the hell cuz i've seen this kind of
thing happen yeah and i was like y'all
some disloyal [ __ ]
yes I've seen that I was like why don't
you a [ __ ] something and you became a
kid yeah but I think Kim's just
everybody wait who which one there's
thank you there are several members in
the kynges that I'm like I know you're a
part of another crew have you have you
ever been in a dance-off they find the
dogs are like for honor someone
disrespects you and you're like let's
have a [ __ ] dance-off and then you
guys have an answer story like you're
walking at the mall with your girlfriend
and then shoulder bounce your girlfriend
and then they're like hey no you start
snapping fingers or you gotta be like
[ __ ] beat it or they wouldn't [ __ ]
tigers and you have a [ __ ] fake fake
slit switchblade and you have a knife
fight and [ __ ] and you look like you've
never held a knife in your life and
Michael Jackson comes in with his piano
shirt like stop it guys no Michael
Jackson had a white dad teach him how to
use the knife he had the Peter Pan
actress from Broadway but cuckoo hopping
I don't I feel like it depends it
depends on the individual depends on the
crew and I think it's a little different
from back then to now everything's more
shared so yeah yeah yeah cuz I've heard
there were a lot of Jabbawockeez that
weren't Jabbawockeez oh yeah I think
like that generation that was more if it
happened then it would be like oh what's
he doing in that creepy thing but it
seems like now the dance world is more
like individual and then they kind of
like they'll start coming to it like you
have things like the lab or like royal
family that is a crew but other than
them I don't know anyone right right
I feel like definition of crew is a
little different to now what's the
definition of crew cuz I just still a
noun or is it a different yeah yeah yeah
no I feel I don't know it was really
more because maybe there's less business
stuff hmm oh it was our pure not that is
it now it is about it was bound with it
was about to dance and not about the
money like it's just evolving it's
changed yeah
that's more about the money you like I
don't want to say more I think it's it's
a factor whereas before oh there's more
of just the dance and that means family
and I mean that I think we wish they
would that option but it wasn't you know
and I feel that it's time to change that
became quite too so this is mainly like
who you like to practice and hang out
with yeah yeah yeah so it's really like
just it's just your curse your homies
and you know that's just as how that's
true cuz now I would see it as a company
like I see kynges as a crew but they're
also a company right right so like if
they need to perform something and then
like maybe they need to hire some break
dancers or whatever that they're men who
can't good it's like oh I could see how
that works but I also go but the gang
side of me is saying that's so disloyal
I know what you mean I know you mean but
it's just one of those things that you
know it's like you have to sacrifice one
thing to get the other kind of thing
yeah have you ever had to kick somebody
out cuz they don't have the moves how
does that conversation go right bro your
waves you don't have don't move you just
no matter you can't do like papi La
Crosse and like that is why it's not
work they're like I don't think you'll
be a part of the first places like
alright see people can lose the move you
know lost the move and they're like oh
you gotta get out here yeah no I'm sure
it happens somewhere thank you imagine
even like you know with age like your
body doesn't move the same right light
your fires yeah I feel like if you ever
seen them I got like a dancer looking in
the mirror and they're like I lost my
moves
plenty yeah really but the sight you
just have to adjust to what you have now
yeah we can't get any dirt on this I
want to know
oh and I love the kurios know I know
it's really true how does the initiation
and like joining initiation there's like
I'm so curious like how do you know
you're a part like it is there like a UH
like a like not hazing but like is there
like levels like a biker gang you know
like like earning your stripes yeah
you're the prospect you know you're a
hang around and then you [ __ ] joy
the ranks and then one day they have a
dinner and you're like here's your
jacket like that is it it's a little bit
a little bit like that like when can
they start wearing purple like that's
your guys's call the right yeah I mean
do i I feel I was alone such a long time
duper fun no more
well so take the purple away no it's
just a combination of different things
it's not like a formal initiation but
the thing is even if you might have a
skill of 10 if you have a [ __ ]
personality yeah that was Colleen you do
that you're probably not good to work
with you know so if you have a skill of
10 and your 4 as a person we would much
rather have someone that's 8 in a 8
personality oh yeah yeah you just won't
get it long so I think it's just being
around them and you know I just bye boys
I'm sure you guys have that and you feel
it to you yup thank you I like give you
around twos threes three personality to
talent okay weird it's almost so good at
dance but there's such a dick but
they're so [ __ ] good a dance it's
beautiful and it makes you cry when you
see them dance oh that's a difficult
[ __ ] zero no I mean respects of them
but you know they can just do it all
know what I probably could do that I
don't do it yeah I really I'm curious
like what really qualifies like you know
in the world of dance
yeah everyone's so great and like their
own little fields or whatever especially
now extraordinary mmm
I'm sure there's bunch of different
opinions but I do reckon I like
uniqueness you know I feel like it's
especially in this day and age it's
really hard because everyone's good now
anything to you know but I feel like
back then before information was shared
more it was like I remember like the
first Street Fighter when characters are
so distinct you know you have your flaws
but you also have these different colors
and I feel like now everything is brown
musics like that you yeah it's it's good
it's amazing but it's like the same and
I feel like just preference wise I like
different shape
you know what your favorite dancer oh
[ __ ] any one of your top ten or crew you
can't say Michael Jackson right now or
just in general like is there someone
that you're like okay this guy or this
girl or this crew always inspires me or
inspired me I bet you he's so next level
he looks at a monkey and goes that's my
that's my splashing I definitely take
more inspiration outside of whatever
subject talent yeah because it's like
it's too straightforward if it's in
there already already exist like I feel
like I talk to you about comedy yeah
just have to get it from something else
oh one monkey peeing on another monkeys
face and having a ball like that's the
best and then the monkey that's getting
peed on looked surprised yeah so he
doesn't know where the water is coming
from and he's like confused and [ __ ]
yeah my vaudeville yeah cuz you do I
like art
yep performance art and stuff too right
yeah yeah yeah it's really to me it's
like the same thing if I use my own body
I'm dancing if I'm conducting people and
choreographing not the whole thing you
directing if you're doing a different
medium it's art but I don't know I just
always like creating stuff you know do
you guys do you guys consider some dance
to be hack like a you guys like all that
square dancing all that electric slide
that's your tack like uh like in the
comedy realm I give you [ __ ] a stand-up
comedy's always talking my balls sucking
dick or like porno jokes it's like oh
this guy's really hacky Mike you trying
to go for like the cheap laughs it's not
really being clever with this job yeah
is there like a move happy dance
yeah [ __ ] um I think I can you grab this
nuts like I always try to be Michael
Jackson I don't think I've ever I think
the closest thing would be stuff now
that might be very viral but not much
technique will be like the closest thing
but then again I am tic TOCs by the last
body that like if it attracts that many
people there must be some kind of value
somewhere yeah
you're too damn secure about your heart
yeah
guy apart too sly though because
pretentious artists are so [ __ ]
hilarious
I want you to be like square dancing is
not dance yeah real dance no I am very
bad perspective I think because movement
is movement right yeah honestly I don't
even care if people call what I do is
not darkness all right cool
do you consider Dances with Wolves a
dance movie that's the best dance movie
he's unbreakable
[Music]